- I'm going to make a bold prediction.
You probably don't like
people stealing your identity
which allows them to steal your money.
Or maybe tell the whole
universe what you're up to
and being able to track
you and your family,
and compromise your security.
These don't feel like good things.
And so, if that is true
of you, it's true of me.
I don't like any of those things.
I wanna keep my private
information private,
then you should care about data security.
And that's what we're
going to do in this unit.
You're gonna learn a lot
about personally identifiable information.
Your name is one example,
but also things like your
social security number,
or things that are indirectly,
personally identifiable
like your address, or your phone number,
why that's important.
And then we're going to learn the ways
that people are going to
try to get ahold of it,
and why they want to get ahold of it.
Because they might wanna misrepresent you,
or or publish things
about you on the Internet,
or control your presence on the internet,
or steal money from you or from
others that you care about.
And then we're going to learn
about ways to protect from those.
A lot of that's going to be
behavior change on your part
to be a little bit more vigilant,
but also technology ways of
keeping your data secret,
encrypting your data, authentication,
making sure that the person
who says they are who they are,
are actually them.
So enjoy this unit on data security.
It isn't just interesting, which it is.
It could save you a lot of money,
a lot of pain, and a lot of embarrassment.